nous sommes nombreux à être rassemblés
ce soir pour défendre une certaine idée
de la décentralisation une certaine idée
des rapports entre l'état des
territoires
une certaine idée de la république et ce
soir ma place était d'être parmi vous
comme président du sénat oui c'est un
geste politique scherrer v morin vous
êtes nombreux à être rassemblés pour
être d'abord ensemble des forces de
proposition
car c'est bien de l'avenir de notre
république décentralisée dont il s'agit
c'est vrai que la tension existentielle
entre unité et diversité entre jacobins
et girondins a traversé et continue à
traverser notre histoire
c'est vrai que notre république qui a
hérité de la monarchie unificatrice et
du bonapartisme mekhissi il ya 36 ans un
ministre de l'intérieur maire de
marseille sous l'autorité de françois
mitterrand a bouleversé les choses
puis jacques chirac et jean pierre
raffarin en 2003 et tout à l'heure a été
rappelé l'article 1er de notre
constitution
une république une une et indivisible
mais une organisation décentralisée
on pourrait penser c'est à françois
barois que la décentralisation et est
désormais inscrite dans le sens de
l'histoire et de l'évolution de notre
pays
on voit que certains ne l'acceptent
toujours pas le président la république
nous avait promis un pacte girondins
souvenons nous c'était en juillet 2017
au sénat avec un objectif que nous avons
partagé de renouer le dialogue qui
s'étaient dégradées entre l'état les
collectivités territoriales
depuis plusieurs années après il faut le
dire cette année de bouleversements et
de réformes incessantes il fallait
plutôt qu'on retrouve la voie de la
confiance de la stabilité et du prêt
mathis comment ne pas accueillir alors
positivement une volonté de dialogue et
de concertation
une promesse souvenons nous de respect
des élus et des collectivités même si un
mot malheureux avait fait du nombre une
espèce j'allais dire d'objectifs qui en
soi aurait pu résumer cette relation
aussi essentiel de la pram de 550000
élus locaux qui sont leurs pairs de la
république et le maillage qui permet en
cas de crise de tenir
j'ai pour ma part un souvenir très
précis c'était en novembre 2015 après le
drame du bataclan autour d'eux qu'ils
étaient nos concitoyens autour de leur
maire
autour de leur mairie parce que c'était
devenu de points de repère et le poids
la croche
parce que chaque commune est une petite
république dans la grande
alors en ce début d'été aux trois
associations aux maires de france
départements de france ces régions de
france ont dénoncé ce qui leur
apparaissait au bout du compte est une
démarche de recentralisation et une
absence d'écouté de compréhension des
collectivités locales elles en ont tiré
les conséquences en ce qui en se
retirant de la conférence nationale des
territoires j'étais présent à cette
conférence nationale des territoires et
je pense que j'ai exprimé le désir à la
fois de renouer le dialogue mais qu'on
ne pouvait plus continuer ainsi